في لبنان يعقده البرلمان اليوم الجلسه
الثامنه لانتخاب رئيس الجمهوريه خلف
للرئيس السابق المنتهى ولاته ميشال عونك
سابقه في انتخاب رئيس البلاد بعد تعذر
حصولي اي مرشح على الثلثي الاصوات او لعدم
اكتمال النصاب المقرر بحضوره ثلثي اعضاء
البرلمان وحدد نصاب الاصوات اللازمه
لانتخاب الرئيس بغالبيه الثلثين في الدوره
الاولى من التصويت والغالبيه المطلقه في
الدورات التاليه
ورقه بيضاء
من البرلمان اللبناني مجلس النواب
ان ذلك فرزا للاصوات
عاده ما يكتمل النصاب في الجلسه الاولى
دون ان
يحصل اي مرشحه على اغلبيه الثلاثين ثم
الجلسه التي تاتيها وتليها لا يكتمل
النصاب هذا ما اعتدنا عليه في الجلسات
السبع السابقه ومن امام البرلمان اللبناني
في بيروت تنضم الينا مراسله الجزيره كارمن
جوخدار اي معلومات جديده كارمن
يعني ليس فقط معلومات جديده ولكن انما هذا
المشهد يتكرر للمره الثامنه على التوالي
هذا ما قاله عدد من النواب ان هناك سامن
في صفوفهم من تكرار هذا المشهد وعدم قدره
البرلمان على التوصل لانتخاب رئيس البلاد
لهذه المحاوله هي الثامنه ويتم الحديث عن
انه في المرحله المقبله ربما لن يكون هناك
جلسات هذه الجلسات الاسبوعيه التي يدعو
اليها رئيس البرلمان اللبناني نبيه بري
المتوقع وهو الذي سيجري في هذه الجلسه ان
الاقتراع سيجري في الجلسه الاولى او في
الدوره الاولى ولن يحصل اي من المرشحين
والمرشحين ربما الوحيد هو ميشال معوض في
كل مره يحصل على عدد من الاصوات ولكن هذه
الاصوات لا تكفي ليصل الى سده رئاسه
الجمهوريه تنافسه في هذه الانتخابات وفي
في هي الجلسات الورقه البيضاء وايضا هناك
عدد من النواب التغييرين ليصوتن لي عصام
خليفه وهو استاذ محاضر في الجامعه
اللبنانيه بالاضافه الى عدد من الشعارات
التي يتم الاقتراع بها اليوم اهميه هذا
الاستحقاق والاستمرار بما يصفه البعض
بالحلقه المفرغه والعباسيه في هذه الجلسات
اهميته انه يجري في ظل اوضاع اقتصاديه
صعبه جدا وفي ظل عدم العقاد لمجلس الوزراء
اذا استحقاقاتهم دائما الناحيه الاقتصاديه
ومن الاوضاع المعيشيه الصعبه جدا على كاهل
المواطنين هذا الفراغ الرئاسي وهذا الشهور
في سوده الرئاسه ليس الاول نذكر جيدا انه
قبل انتخابي ميشال العون حصل اكثر من 40
دعوه لعقد لاجراء لانتخابات الرئاسيه
واستمر الشعور في سوده الرئاسه لنحو سنتين
ونصف اليوم المشهد مرشح لا صار هذا الشهور
لبعد فتره الاعياد في الاشهو في الشهر
المقبل لتعود وتنطلق هذه
الجلسات ننتظر النتيجه نتيجه فرز الاصوات
وبطبيعه الحال بما سيكون سيكون هناك جلسه
اخرى او دوره اخرى للانتخاب ام ستؤجل هذه
الانتخابات الى موعد يحدد لاحقا يحدده
بطبيعه الحاره الرئيس
من بيروت شكرا جزيلا لك